[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos a mais uma live dos
apoiadores da comunidade fechada do
canal do YouTube do Dr. Alan. Temos
somente uma pergunta hoje. Então, a
partir do momento que eu responder essa
pergunta, nós vamos ver as perguntas ao
vivo e eu também vou discutir alguns
artigos interessantes para vocês. Bem,
pergunta: "Doutor, qual seria o
tratamento recomendado para diminuir ou
eliminar nódulos de tireoide?
visto que nutricionista Diogo Deja ou
Derra, não sei como é que pronuncia,
afirma que consegue retrair nódulos
tirades 3 e 4. Aí ele manda o link do
vídeo, não assisti o vídeo, mas é um
assunto recorrente, é um assunto que já
discutimos aqui lives anteriores.
Basicamente a gente recomenda uso de
nutrientes, iodo, selênio,
em casos específicos, vitamina D de
dado, verificar se tem zinco e cobre
suficientemente, vão ver os exames, e
também vitaminas do complexo B, mas e
tem outros tratamentos que também vou
discutir com vocês.
Os nódulos classificados como tirad 3 e
4, eles têm um risco de malignidade que
pode variar de 5 a 20%, tá?
5% no caso tirades 3 e mais para 20%
no caso do tirades 4. Só que o tir 4
também dependendo do tamanho pode ser de
5 a 20% de risco. Então a evidência
atual tem várias abordagens terapêuticas
eficazes. Aqui a gente vai discutir
tanto as ortodoxas quanto as da medicina
funcional.
Isso inclui tratamentos minimamente
invasivos, que tem uma taxa de redução
volumétrica em torno de 67 a 93%. E
protocolos nutricionais, que eu já
pincelei aqui, mas eu vou dar mais
detalhes que demonstraram redução
significativa do tamanho do nódulo.
Então, a evolução natural desses nódulos
benignos mostra que de 80 a 85% deles
permanecem do mesmo tamanho, estáveis ao
longo de 5 anos. existe um risco anual
de malignização menor que 0,6%.
Então, vale muito a pena fazer o
acompanhamento conservador.
Boa noite, Alice Vg, obrigado estar
comparecendo ao vivo na live. Então,
estudos prospectivos multicêntricos,
demonstrando que a maioria dos nódulos
citologicamente benignos não apresenta
crescimento significativo. Isso
justifica o manejo conservador como
primeira linha para os casos que não têm
sintomas.
Qual que é a novidade em termos de
medicina ortodoxa para tratamento desses
nódulos? A ablação por radiofrequência.
Então essa ambulação por
radiofrequência, ela surgiu como
tratamento não cirúrgico mais eficaz,
com estudos realizados na América do
Norte em 2022, 620 nódulos que foram
tratados em que houve redução
volumétrica de 67 a 75%
em 12 meses. Para nódulos menores de 30
ml de volume, a taxa de redução
volumétrica atinge 75%.
com preservação da função tiroidiana em
mais de 95% dos pacientes. Então, as
complicações maiores ocorrem em menos de
2% dos casos. Isso estabelece um
excelente perfil de segurança. Tivemos o
estudo holandês em 2025 com 337
pacientes em que foi confirmado esses
resultados que eu acabei de falar e
também mostrou manutenção da redução
volumétrica em acompanhamento por 5
anos. Então, a técnica é eficaz para
nódulos sólidos sintomáticos, que as
pessoas possam ter algum tipo de
desconforto e a melhora dos sintomas
compressivos em mais de 90% dos
pacientes tratados.
Então vamos falar agora da medicina
funcional integrativa.
Então
houve um estudo, o ensaio clínico Lisa,
com 1024 pacientes, em que foi
demonstrado que a suplementação de iodo
isolada ou combinada com o livro
tiroxina, né, o hormônio tiroidano o T4,
reduziu significativamente o volume
nodular ao longo de 12 meses. Então,
iodo, sim, é comprovado estudos, ensaios
que ele funciona,
mas vai funcionar melhor ainda se a
gente combinar os nutrientes. Então,
estudos clínicos revelaram que a
combinação de selênio 200 microg
inozitol, nesse caso eles não puseram
iodo, então era selênio 200 microg com
1000 inozitol 600 mg diariamente. Isso
resultou em 76% de redução no tamanho
nos nódulos mistos, uma melhora de 56%
na rigidez do nódulo. Então essa
abordagem representa uma alternativa não
invasiva com evidência robusta de
eficácia.
Temos um outro protocolo também
envolvendo a combinação de espirulina,
curcumina e bozuéliia serrata. Então é
16 mg de espirulina, 200 mg de curcumina
e 200 mg de bozuélia. Diariamente teve
um ensaio clínico duplo cego controlado
por placebo com 34 pacientes usando um
sistema, em que foi demonstrado 85%
dos participantes tiveram redução do
tamanho do nódulo com diminuição média
de 0,6
cm qu compocebo.
Então, já falamos iodo, selênio,
miinositol,
agora espirulina, curcumina e bozuélia
serrata. Então tem bastante coisa dá
para fazer, fora que eu já comentei,
vitamina D, complexo B, zinco,
cobre, né?
Então, falando especificamente do
selênio, nós sabemos que ele é um
mineral com características
antioxidantes, que ele faz parte das
enzimas antioxidantes gluta peroxidase e
também é um cofator essencial para
deiodinas, que são os enzimas que
transformam o T4 em T3. Então ele é
fundamental como nutriente e é um
mineral que tem bastante taxas aí de
deficiência na população, especialmente
no Brasil que o solo é baixo em seleno.
Então a dose terapêutica de 100 a 200
microg por dia por pelo menos 6 meses
reduz os anticorpos antitpo e
antitiroglobulina. Então tem um
protocolo que eu uso, por exemplo,
consultório, que eu uso metiformina com
selênio e é muito bom para reduzir os
anticorpos e também o selênio ajuda a
melhorar a estrutura ultrassonográfica
da tireoide. Então, estudos transestais
mostraram uma correlação inversa entre
níveis de selênio e formação de
múltiplos nódulos maiores que 10 mm.
Então, é muito importante, iodo,
selênio, zinco, cobre, vitamina D,
complexo B.
A suplementação de iodo requer uma
abordagem cuidadosa, por isso que eu não
estou usando mais lugol na minha prática
de rotina. Concentrações urinárias
ótimas desse elemento do iodo é de 200 a
400 mg por L. Isso vai estar associado a
uma redução de 37 a 57% no risco de
nódulos se comparado à deficiência. A
dose terapêutica varia entre 150 a 300
mic de áo. Por isso que o iodo na forma
de olugol pode ser excessivo para boa
parte das pessoas.
Porém, essa dose terapêutica poderia ser
contraindicada em alguns casos em que há
hipertiroidismo ativo. Então, é
importante fazer os exames antes. E
devemos sempre monitorar pacientes que
têm Hashimoto que estão utilizando o
iodo.
Apesar que tem aí alguns produtores de
conteúdo falando que o iodo na forma do
iodo kelp seria ruim, seria prejudicial,
que tem que usar o iodo molecular e tudo
mais, não é essa a minha percepção na
minha prática clínica. Nunca tive
problema com o iodo kelp. A vitamina D
de dado é importante para regular a
priferação celular, então por isso que é
interessante para utilizar em pessoas
que tm nódulo de tireoide.
Então existe uma correlação
significativa entre a deficiência de
vitamina D e maior ocorrência e maior
tamanho dos nódulos tirodianos. Então a
suplementação tem que ser pelo menos em
caso de deficiência leve 2.000 por dia.
Em caso de deficiências moderadas 10.000
por dia. Em caso de deficiências muito
graves, aí eu uso até 20.000 por dia.
Então nós temos que atingir níveis
séricos acima de 40, na minha opinião,
entre 40 e 70, mas tem fontes que falam
que é 30.
Isso tem efeitos antiproliferativos
porque modula o receptor VDR no tecido
tiriodiano, tá? Dieta mediterrânea é uma
das mais estudadas, vocês sabem disso,
já falei muito aqui no canal. A dieta
meditrânea, ela reduz também o risco de
nódulos da tiriodide. Um estudo piloto
de 2022 em que foram arregimentados 794
participantes revelou uma descoberta.
Baixa adesão à dieta mediterrânea
aumentou o risco de doença nodular
tirudiana em 6,1
vezes, ou seja, bastante. Então a dieta
antiinflamatória, né? Eles estudaram
aqui a dieta mediterrânea porque é a
mais famosa, digamos assim. Mas eu
acredito que isso pode ser estendido
para qualquer dieta antiinflamatória.
Então,
existe um score chamado predmed. E esse
score quando ele tá abaixo de cinco, ele
prediz presença de nódulos com 75% de
precisão. Equanto que os scores abaixo
de quatro predizem nódulos de alto
risco, 92%
de acurácia.
Então, quem estava consumindo uma dieta
mediterrânea, ou seja, azeite de oliva
extra virgem, peixes ricos em ômega-3,
mais três porções semanais, vegetais
coloridos, mais duas poções diárias,
frutas, nozes leguminosas,
estavam mais protegido contra os
nódulos. Então, o mecanismo protetor
envolve a redução de citocinas
pró-inflamatórias e marcadoras de
estresse oxidativo.
Existe aquela história dos alimentos que
ajudam a formar o bócio, né, os
alimentos bosciogênicos.
Porém, existe um pouco de mito em cima
disso, um exagero em cima do brócolis,
em cima dos alimentos crucíferos.
Então, contrariando crenças populares, o
consumo moderado de vegetais crucíferos
cozidos tem risco mínimo, a não ser que
vocês sejam tarado por alimento
crucífero, né? Então, cozimento reduz a
atividade bociogênica desses vegetais em
30 a 90%, dependendo do método que você
vai utilizar. A fervura por 30 minutos
com o descarte da água elimina 90% dos
compostos bociogênicos, mantendo os
benefícios nutricionais e as
propriedades anticancerígenas.
Então, existe aqui umas observações
sobre tratamentos farmacológicos.
Livro toroxina T4, o uso supressivo
desse hormônio é uma abordagem
controversa. Então, houve uma
metaanálise de 11 estudos. se juntaram
aos estudos e fizeram uma estatística
única,
isso
compondo 743 pacientes e que
demonstrou-se que a supressão com
levotiroxina, ou seja, doses um
pouquinho mais altas, poderia dobrar a
chance de redução nodular, mas não seria
recomendado pelas principais diretrizes
devido aos riscos cardiovasculares e
ósseos.
Então, a dose média necessária paraa
supressão do TSH, que seria 2,8
microgia,
se associava a um maior risco de
fibrilação atrial e osteoporose.
Vamos falar um pouquinho sobre uma téc
ablação percutânea com etanol. Para
nódulos císticos ou predominantemente
císticos, existe uma téc abação com
etanol, que é um tipo de álcool.
Isso permanece como tratamento de
primeira linha quando é
predominantemente cístico, com redução
volumétrica de 80 90%. Excelente custo
benefício, requer média de três sessões,
dois a três sessões, com complicações
maiores, extremamente raras.
Então, houve uma comparação em terapias
minimamente invasivas
e análise mais recente classifica as
técnicas por eficácia de redução na
seguinte ordem de preferência quando se
fala em 12 meses de acompanhamento.
Então, radiofrequência, duas sessões,
teve 79% de redução. Rádiofrequência,
sessão única, teve 76% de redução.
ablação por microondas teve 65%,
ablação a laser 49%,
e etanol para esses nódulos que tem
componente predominantemente cístico, 80
a 90% de redução. Então, a escolha da
técnica depende da composição nodular.
Então, radiofrequência para sólidos,
etanol para císticos e todas as técnicas
preservam função tiroidiana melhor que a
cirurgia, com taxa de hipotiroidismo pós
procedimento menores que 5%.
verso, se fosse fazer a cirurgia, tirar
tirar o lobo inteiro da tireoide, seria
de 20 a 30%.
Ã, então eu levantei um pouquinho sobre
os protocolos
brasileiros e que eu pude ver que o
Diogo Deja ou Derra, né, é um educador
físico brasileiro que tem pós-graduação
em nutrição esportiva
e, segundo ele também homeostase
hormonal feminina. Ele desenvolveu um
método chamado método ESS, que
integraria a análise hormonal completa,
suplementação personalizada e
modificações dietéticas.
Ele teria atendido 12.000 pessoas e a
abordagem dele enfatizaria avalia
hormonal abrangente,
ocorreção de deficiências nutricionais
antes do ajuste, equipe multidisciplinar
com endocrinologista e nutricionista e
protocolos individualizados baseados em
exames laboratoriais.
Ele não tem protocolos publicados
específicos para nódulos tirodianos, mas
o que ele faz é basicamente que nós
fazemos no consultório de medicina
funcional, né? Só que ele deve ter
empacotado isso de maneira mais bonita,
com melhor marketing, por isso chamou
atenção.
Bem, já falei bastante sobre esse
assunto, deixa eu só completar agora com
alguns dados sobre toxinas ambientais,
exuptores endócrinos. Nós sabemos que
exposição aos fitalados aumenta o risco
de nódulos malignos em 15 a 85%
através da mediação do estresse
oxidativo. O bisfenol a presente em
plásticos e revestimentos de latas
associa a risco 14 vezes maior de câncer
tiroidiano em alta exposição. Tome
cuidado, então, com os plásticos.
Não esquentem os plásticos no
microondas. Não usem plástico na
geladeira. Evitem garrafas plásticas
para tomar água.
Eu sei que é muito difícil, mas tentem,
né?
Bem, então só falar rapidamente, o
tirads 3, você só vai fazer a pulsão
biópsa se ele tiver acima de 2,5 cm de
diâmetro, né? O maior nódulo.
O tirad 4 só faria a punção se o nódulo
for acima de 1,5 cm de diâmetro, tá?
Então, fora isso, acompanhamento anual.
Bem, vamos ver aqui os comentários ao
vivo.
Eh, poderia, por favor, falar um pouco
sobre Lipedema. A Dra. Ana Paulo seria a
melhor candidata a isso. Vou ver se eu
chamo ela para participar da próxima
live e ela comentar sobre Lipedema.
Não deixa esquecer desse assunto, Itaci,
para a gente poder na semana que vem
chamar ela para ver se ela pode
participar da live. Se ela ti aparecer
por hoje aqui, eu peço para ela falar
sobre o assunto.
200 mg de vitamina B6 antes domir.
Melhor a lembrança dos sonhos depois que
acorda?
Não sei, Eliseu, nunca li nada a
respeito. Consumir a planta galantamina.
Galantamina não é planta, é uma droga
para Alzheimer, tá? É um melhor a
lembrança dos sonhos depois que acorda.
Não conheço planta galantamina, conheço
a droga galantamina que é uma um
bloqueador, né, da da enzima que degrada
acetilcolina, né, um bloqueador de
acetil colinesterase,
que é tratamento para
doença de Alzheimer, mas é um tratamento
paliativo.
Boa noite, Denise.
Perina a é um suplemento, não é uma
planta, tá? E realmente eu não vou saber
responder as suas perguntas, viu Eliseu?
Porque não é uma coisa assim que no
consultório faz muita diferença. Ninguém
vem aqui me perguntar como é que faz
para melhorar a lembrança dos sonhos.
Então a gente pode pesquisar esse
assunto, mas a princípio eu não conheço
sobre isso. Tá
bem? Vamos lá. Vamos discutir alguns
artigos aqui.
Quanto quanto temos? Nós temos já de
live. Temos 18 minutos.
Então, queria bater um papo com vocês
sobre uma descoberta que está mudando o
jeito que a gente entende o
envelhecimento cerebral. Na verdade,
nada tão novo assim para quem conhece o
protocolo Recode, mas a ciência ortodoxa
está, a medicina ortodoxa está aos
pouquinhos incorporando os conceitos do
protocolo recod.
Então, nós sabemos, nós conhecemos
aquela história de que depois de 60 anos
a memória vai caindo e muita gente se
resigna com isso, só que não é bem
assim. Então, a ciência está aos poucos
entendendo e admitindo que isso não é
uma coisa inexorável. Nós podemos
combater isso de uma maneira bem natural
e a solução não tá numa pílula mágica ou
num tratamento caríssimo, está no estilo
de vida, né? você pode começar hoje
mesmo fazer uma prevenção de déficit
cognitivo. Então temos a seguinte
situação, mais de 2.000 americanos,
todos entre 60 e 80 anos, que
participaram de um estudo chamado US
Pointer. E eram pessoas que a gente
chama de risco aumentado, que eram
sedentárias, com alimentação meio ruim,
pressão nas alturas, alguns com
histórico
é ruim também de família.
Então é aquela típica situação que você
vê todo dia como aquele seu tio que vive
no sofá comendo salgadinho, né? Tá esse
perfil aí do americano que come junk
food.
Aí os pesquisadores fizeram algo genial.
Eles dividiram essa turba em dois grupos
e acompanharam por dois anos inteiros.
Um grupo recebeu o que eles chamaram de
intervenção estruturada, né, que nada
mais é que uma coisa parecido com o
protocolo, protocolo recode.
Então era uma espécie de acompanhamento
personalizado, como se fosse um personal
trainer, um programa completo com 38
encontros ao longo de 2 anos. E nesses
encontros tinha de tudo, tinha exercício
aeróbico, musculação,
implementação da dieta mediterrânea com
toque de dash, aquela dieta americana
que se usa para controlar a pressão
arterial.
E também eram feitos exercícios mentais,
jogos e desafios,
atividades sociais e monitoramento
cardíaco. Então, o pessoal tinha metas
específicas, tipo fazer 30 minutos de
exercício aeróbico por dia. E o mais
legal é que faziam tudo em grupo,
criando então aquela situação de
eh um ajudando um outro, um entre aspas
pressionando o outro. Então o outro
grupo também recebeu orientações, mas
era mais um esquema se vira aí te dou
informação e você se vira nos 30.
Então, receberam material educativo,
seis reuniões básicas só para aprender
as coisas e foram estimulados a fazer
mudanças por conta própria. Então, era
mais ou menos aquela situação de você
malhar sozinho na academia ou malhar com
personal training. Então, essa era a
diferença básica aí entre os dois
grupos. ou mesmo outra analogia é a
diferença entre ter um professor
particular e estudar sozinho pelo
YouTube, né?
Então aí vem o resultado que deixou todo
mundo perplexo, né? Os dois grupos
melhoraram a cognição perplexo porque
eles não conhecem o protocolo recode,
né? Então o grupo que teve
acompanhamento estruturado, obviamente,
né? com tantas reuniões aí que tiveram,
teve um ganho maior. Então, para vocês
terem uma ideia, o cérebro dessas
pessoas funcionava como se elas fossem
de um a 2 anos mais jovens. Depois o
pessoal fala que não funciona o
protocolo recode, né? Lógico que esse
estudo não foi sobre protocolo recode,
mas é muito parecido em princípio.
Então é como se o tempo nesses
indivíduos tivesse dado marcha ré.
Então, a função executiva, aquela que a
gente usa para planejar, organizar,
tomar decisões, foi a que mais melhorou.
E o mais impressionante, não importava
se a pessoa era homem ou mulher, ou a
raça, ou se tinha o gene apo e4, tão
temido gene que aumenta o risco em muito
do Alzheimer, né? Crtinho tem uma cópia
de apo e4, aumenta o risco em
aproximadamente quatro vezes. Quem tem
duas cópias aumenta o risco em 16. Mas
nesse estudo o AP4 não fez muita
diferença.
Então, mostrando a importância do estilo
de vida.
Mas esa aí, não é só fazer uma caminhada
e comer salada que vai resolver. Vocês
sabem disso, né? O segredo está em
multidomínio, né? você fazer muitas
coisas ao mesmo tempo. Isso que complica
muitas vezes o meu tratamento dos
pacientes aqui no consultório, porque a
gente exige deles que façam várias
coisas para poder tá aderindo ao
protocolo recod.
Temos que necessariamente atacar várias
frentes ao mesmo tempo. Então o cérebro
é como se fosse uma casa que precisa de
manutenção. Não adianta só consertar o
telhado e deixar a fundação ruim, né?
Tem que cuidar de tudo. E foi exatamente
isso que o estudo demonstrou. Então, a
atividade física, nós sabemos, bombeia
mais sangue pro cérebro, melhora a saúde
arterial cerebral, aumenta o marcador,
né, de crescimento, que é o BDNF, o
brain derived neurotropic factor, que
funciona como se fosse um fertilizante
pros neurônios. E a dieta mediterrânea
nesse caso, mas o que nós utilizamos
aqui no consultório é uma dieta
ketoflex, que é uma dieta rica em
vegetais variados e com aumento da
gordura saudável, mas tem muita
semelhança com a mediterrânea.
A única diferença é que a mediterrânea
tem mais carboidrato. Então, nesse caso,
a diata mediterrânea é rica em azeite de
oliva, peixes, vegetais e grãos
integrais, reduziu a inflamação e ajudou
a proteger os vasos sanguíneos
cerebrais.
E os exercícios mentais que foram feitos
também, o desafios cognitivos, criaram
novas conexões neurais, construíram o
que a gente chama de reserva cognitiva,
que é uma poupança de neurônios pro
futuro. E o componente social, que foi
bem interessante nesse caso aqui, né,
esse aspecto aí de
convivência de grupo foi fundamental.
Então, interagir com outras pessoas
estimulou áreas do cérebro que podem
ficar preguiçosas quando a gente está
aposentado e isolado, que é tão comum
nessa faixa de idade, né? Especialmente
quando a gente fica consumindo conteúdo
lixo, como é o caso da TV. Infelizmente
os idosos são muito mais hoje em dia,
né, expostos à TV do que a população
mais jovem que prefere YouTube e redes
sociais.
E tem um detalhe interessante, os
participantes do grupo estruturado, né,
que se encontravam com frequência, iam
puro iam pro clube, eh, o IMCA, né,
aquele da música lá que vocês conhecem,
né, mas aqui no Brasil chama de ACM, né,
Associação Cristão de Moços. Então eles
iam lá pro YMCA, mas não sem aquela
parte lá do, né, do do da do grupo
musical, né, que vocês devem lembrar.
Então eles aprendiam a usar os
equipamentos direitinho lá. Eles tinham
um acompanhamento muito próximo. Tinha
uma senhora chamada Jones, que era da
cidade de Aurora em Ilóis, que nunca
tinha pisado uma academia na vida e ela
ficou perdida no começo, mas com o apoio
do grupo e dos instrutores, em poucos
meses ela já estava bem interada lá nos
aparelhos, suando a camisa e adorando,
né? Então isso que faz toda a diferença.
Esse suporte é muito bom ter alguém te
guiando e ter um grupo apoiando.
E não foi só nos Estados Unidos, não.
Então houve também na Finlândia o estudo
Finger que mostrou resultados bem
parecidos. Então vocês estão vendo que
eles vão ter que engolir realmente os
resultados do protocolo Record. Na
Austrália eles fizeram um programa
online que durou 3 anos e também
funcionou. Na China estão testando um
aplicativo chamado Cognitive
Evergreenland,
que ajuda idosos a fazer essas
intervenções em casa. Então, o mundo
inteiro aos pouquinhos está descobrindo
que eu já sei e que o Dr. Dale Brad já
sabe também há muito tempo que o cérebro
responde quando a gente faz várias
intervenções juntas de estilo de vida.
E agora vou contar uma coisa que os
pesquisadores descobriram e que faz
sentido, que muita gente não consegue
fazer a manutenção dos hábitos saudáveis
porque tenta fazer sozinha e não tem
apoio. É tipo querer aprender a tocar
violão sem professor, mas demora
muito mais, né? até dá, mas demora muito
mais e a chance de desistir é grande.
Então, no estudo, o grupo teve
acompanhamento estruturado, reuniões
regulares, metas específicas e feedback
constante.
Era tipo ter um coach, como eu comentei,
mas baseado em ciência pura.
Então, o estudo não curiu só gente rica
e com PhD. Tinha gente de todas as
etnias, níveis socioeconômicos
diferentes, pessoas com sem ensino
superior e funcionou para todo mundo.
Então isso mostra que mesmo as pessoas
que não tiveram muita formação
intelectual podem ser beneficiadas por
um programa desses e também não precisa
ser milionário para proteger o cérebro,
que nós precisamos de formação, apoio e
dedicação.
Então, os pesquisadores ainda estão
analisando exames de sangue,
ressonâncias nucleares magnéticas e
outros marcadores biológicos para
entender o que aconteceu no cérebro
dessas pessoas. Eles estão precisando
estar uma ligada lá pro de Bradsen, né?
Mas uma coisa já tá clara, quando você
combina exercício físico regular,
alimentação saudável, desafios mentais,
vida social ativa, controle dos fatores
de risco cardiovascular, você cria
obviamente um escudo protetor pro seu
cérebro, né?
E o interessante, o legal é que a
Associação de Alzheimeria lá dos Estados
Unidos está investindo mais de 40
milhões de dólares para levar esse
programa para comunidades em todo o
país. Eles entenderam que não adianta
ter o conhecimento guardado numa gaveta
de universidade, tem que chegar na
população em geral, em todo mundo que
precisa.
Então, se você tem alguém na sua família
que tá começando a desenvolver um dé
cognitivo,
veja os meus vídeos sobre protocolo
recode, estude o assunto e comece a
tentar implementar algo parecido,
né? Se for um idoso que você conhece, vê
se ele se integra melhor em termos de
grupo, passa a caminhar com amigos ou
parentes, montar um grupo de suporte
para trocar receitas saudáveis, pode ser
no WhatsApp, baixar aplicativos, como é
o caso do Lumosit, né, que tem jogos
mentais, também tem outros lá do Supera
do Bren HQ.
E então é muito importante você integrar
esses idosos em grupos de apoio com
suporte para que haja melhores
resultados.
Ah, vamos ver as perguntas ao vivo aqui.
Não, não temos mais perguntas novas
aqui.
Vamos continuar. Então, eh, o próximo
tema que eu queria falar com vocês
é um estudo que saiu em agosto desse ano
na revista Nature, que jogou uma luz
sobre a questão das calorias, aquela
história de contar calorias.
E as descobertas são interessantes.
Então, os cientistas pegaram 55 pessoas
com sobrepeso da Inglaterra, fizeram um
experimento super interessante.
Dividiram esse grupo em, aliás,
dividiram a turma em dois grupos.
Ambos receberam dietas que seguiam as
diretrizes oficiais de alimentação
saudável do governo britânico. Mesmas
calorias, mesma quantidade de proteínas,
carboidratos, gorduras, fibras, ou seja,
a mesma composição de macronutrientes,
tudo igualzinho. E a única diferença é
que um grupo comia comida de verdade,
comida sem ser altamente processada,
tipo aquela que a sua avó fazia em casa,
ou seja, e o outro grupo, lasanha
congelada de supermercado, barrinha de
cereal e sanduíche pronto, ultra
processados que muita gente come todos
os dias para não ter que mexer com
cozinha ou na correria.
E muitos desses que prometem ser
saudáveis, né?
E aí que vem o pulo do gato. Depois de 8
semanas, o pessoal que comeu comida de
verdade perdeu o dobro do peso da turma
que estava comendo processados, mesmo
comendo a mesma composição de calorias e
de macronutrientes.
Então, a turma adulta processado perdeu
cerca de 1% peso corporal. A turma da
comida minimamente processada perdeu 2%
do
peso. Lembrando que a mesma caloria que
eles tiveram, tá, ingeriram exatamente a
mesma caloria.
Então isso foi em apenas semanas, sem
ninguém fazer esforço consciente para
comer menos. Vamos estavam comendo
dentro das calorias planejadas, mas sem
outros eh características diferentes,
né? Então, se a gente projetar isso para
um ano inteiro, seria uma diferença de
13%
versus 4% de perda de peso nos homens e
9%
versus 5% nas mulheres. Então, seria uma
diferença grande em um ano, né? Então,
mais interessante é que o grupo de
comida de verdade comeu 290 calorias a
menos por dia de forma natural. Ou seja,
eles calcularam as calorias iguais, mas
no final o grupo que comia comida de
verdade acabou comendo menos.
Não passaram fome, tá? Por conta disso,
já o pessoal do ultraprocessado comeu só
120 calorias a menos.
E olha que interessante, quem comeu
comida minimamente processada relatou
muito menos desejo por comida em geral,
menos daqueles cravings que o americano
chama, né, que é o a compulsão, né, de
comer alguma alguma coisa, aquela
vontade louca de atacar a geladeira.
Então, a galera tinha quatro vezes mais
controle sobre os desejos por comida
salgada e duas vezes mais resistência
àquela comidinha que mais desejavam.
E
tem uma outra parte interessante aqui.
Isso prova que não é só sobre calorias.
O que acontece é que os ultraprocessados
conseguem literalmente enganar o nosso
organismo. O nosso corpo tem um sistema
super sofisticado para regular fome e
saciedade. É uma orquestra de vários
hormônios, né, de vários transmissores,
como é o caso de grelina, leptina, GLP1,
PY, né, que é o polipeptídio intestinal
e insulina.
Quando você come comida de verdade, essa
orquestra funciona direitinho. A grelina
é o hormônio da fome. Quando você come
comida de verdade, ele cai. E a leptina
e o GLP1, que são os horônios também da
saciedade, eles sobem e você
naturalmente para de comer quando está
satisfeito ou satisfeita. E os
ultraprocessados bagunçam esses
hormônios. Eles são formulados para
serem hiperpalatáveis, ou seja,
irresistíveis ao paladar da maioria das
pessoas. Eles combinam açúcar, gordura
hidrogenada, sal, um monte de aditivos
numa proporção que não existe na
natureza e é uma bomba de sabor vazia de
nutrientes
e que dispara os circuitos de recompensa
do cérebro, aquela mesma via
dopaminética que está envolvida em
vícios. Então, o cérebro fica pedindo
mais, fica cada vez querendo mais. É o
que eu falo aos pacientes, não adianta
você comer com moderação alimentos que
geram impulsos de você comer cada vez
mais, né? Então, essa história de que
pode comer de tudo, que não tem problema
nenhum, é só ser moderado nas coisas, é
uma história meio furada, porque quando
você começa a comer açúcar e doce, o seu
cérebro fica pedindo mais e mais, fica
viciado
naquele mecanismo de viapamnética, né? E
aí você acaba comendo mais do que
deveria.
A velocidade com que você come esses
alimentos também aumenta, tá? Quando
você come os ultraprocessados. Isso é
sinistro, né? Um estudo anterior do
mesmo pesquisador principal que é o
Kevin Hall mostrou que as pessoas que
comem ultra processados comem muito mais
rápido,
né? Então lembra que o cérebro leva
cerca de 20 minutos para processar que
você tá satisfeito, né? É como se fosse
assim um delay, né, um atraso. Então
quando você come rápido demais, já
mandou para dentro um monte de calorias
extras antes do sinal da saciedade
chegar. Então o sistema de freios no seu
apetite fica com defeito. Outro ponto
crucial que o estudo revelou, quem comeu
comida de verdade perdeu gordura
corporal e água, mas manteve a massa
muscular intacta.
Então, mais interessante ainda,
isso é ouro puro para quem quer
emagrecer de forma saudável. O grupo do
ultraprocessado, a pedra de peso foi
menos eficiente em termos de composição
corporal, ou seja, perderam mais músculo
também.
E olha que interessante, os
triglicerídeos, né, as gorduras são
marcadores quando eles são medidos no
sangue, né, de risco cardiovascular,
também melhoraram mais no grupo da
comida minimamente processada.
Bem, vocês podem dizer que no dia a dia
pode ser difícil comer comida de
verdade, né, que no dia a dia é
complicado, que acaba induzindo a gente
a comer os ultraprocessados.
A gente vive numa correria, os ultras
processados estão ali facilmente
acessíveis,
práticos, geralmente mais baratos.
Mas o que esse estudo mostra é que mesmo
quando esses produtos tentam se passar
por saudáveis, né, com rótulos bonitos,
falando de fibras, proteínas, vitaminas
adicionadas, eles continuam sabotando o
nosso organismo. É como colocar gasolina
adulterada no carro, ele vai andar, mas
não vai render o que deveria e ainda
pode dar problema no motor.
Aí vai uma questão social importante que
não podemos ignorar. Os pesquisadores
destacaram que o ambiente alimentar
atual está nos preparando pro fracasso.
Então não é culpa individual sua se tá
difícil emagrecer. O sistema todo está
montado para facilitar o acesso aos
ultraprocessados e dificultar o acesso à
comida de verdade. É uma questão de
política pública, interesses aí mega
corporações
da indústria alimentícia que não querem
tornar a comida saudável mais acessível.
Então o recado está claro, né? Voltar
pro básico funciona aquele arroz com
feijão da vovó, aquela saladinha, o
frango grelhado, legumes refogados. Isso
é medicina preventiva e não precisa ser
perfeito. O estudo mostrou que mesmo
seguindo as diretrizes nutricionais
convencionais, só o fato de escolher
alimentos menos processados já faz uma
diferença enorme.
Uma dica que eu sempre dou e que os
pesquisadores também averiguaram, olhe o
rótulo. tem um monte de ingrediente que
você não reconhece, que não tem na sua
cozinha, que parece nome de experimento
científico, de experimento químico,
provavelmente não é uma boa ideia,
melhor passar batido. Então, procure
alimentos com poucos ingredientes que
você entenda o que são e quando possível
cozinha em casa e não precisa ser
elaborado.
Pode ser uma coisa simples, uma elete
com legumes, uma sopa simples,
sanduíche, se você quiser, com pão sem
glúten, feito na hora. Tudo isso já é
muito melhor do que a versão
ultraprocessada.
E nesse estudo é importante dizer que os
participantes não estavam tentando
emagrecer de forma ativa. Eles podiam
comer o quanto quisessem até 4000
calorias por dia. E mesmo assim,
naturalmente o corpo deles escolheu
comer menos quando estavam comendo
comida de verdade. É como se o organismo
soubesse exatamente do que precisa
quando está sendo sabotado pelos
ultraprocessados.
Então isso tudo confirmou algo que a
gente já suspeitava. Há tempos na
medicina funcional, não é só o que você
come, mas como o seu alimento foi
produzido e processado. Então, matriz
alimentar importa. Quando você destrói a
estrutura natural do alimento e adicione
um monte de coisa e reconstrói numa
forma diferente, você pede muito mais
que nutrientes, você pede a capacidade
do alimento de se comunicar
adequadamente com o seu corpo. Então,
esse estudo nos ensina que comer natural
é a solução pro emagrecimento
sustentável e pode ser mais simples do
que a gente imagina. Não é fazer dieta
muito restrita na maioria das vezes,
não é absolutamente cortar só grupos
alimentares inteiros ou viver contando
calorias. É sobre voltar a comer comida
de verdade,
aquela que os nossos bisavós
reconheceriam como comida. é respeitar a
sabedoria do nosso corpo que evoluiu por
milhões de anos para funcionar
perfeitamente com alimentos naturais e
não com criações de laboratório, né?
Então, procure implementar aos poucos,
troque a barrente de cereal por fruta
com castanhas, substitua o macarrão
instantâneo pro macarrão é normal, sem
glúten, né? com molho caseiro simples.
Prepare a sua aveia na noite anterior em
vez de comprar o potinho pronto. São
mudanças pequenas que, como esse estudo
demonstrou, podem fazer grande diferença
na sua vida e no seu peso. E você vai
comer com mais prazer, com menos
compulsão e com muito mais satisfação.
Tá bom, pessoal?
Ã,
Denise tá perguntando algo aqui. Dr.
Alan, um gato me mordeu. Está demorando
para melhorar. Estou tomando
antibiótico. Será que tem como saber se
esse antibiótico está certo?
Bem,
ã, deixa eu pensar aqui.
Esse gato era vacinado, né? Esse
primeiro ponto é seu gato, Denise?
Porque se fosse um gato estranho, você
teria que tomar vacina antirrábica, tá?
H, agora a respeito de antibióticos, não
tem um jeito de de ver isso, não.
É óbvio que se a sua infecção ficar
muito mais grave,
se Deus quiser, não vai ficar, né? Tô
torcendo muito para isso. Uma coisa
teórica que poderia ser feita era colher
sangue e fazer uma cultura do sangue,
tá? Mas essa cultura só daria positivo
se a infecção fosse mais grave, tá?
Qual o melhor exercício físico para
melhorar a mente? É uma combinação de
aeróbico com exercício de força, tá,
Denise? Então, pelo menos três vezes de
semana a musculação e fazer uma
caminhada todos os dias de 30 minutos no
passo rápido. Seria essa minha dica para
você. Deixa eu ver se alguém mandou mais
pergunta aqui no questionário.
Não mandou. Beleza,
pessoal.
Eu vou encerrar, então. Tô indo para 45
minutos de live. Eu tenho mais alguns
artigos aqui, mas eu vou deixar isso
paraa semana que vem para não
sobrecarregar vocês com informação, tá?
Agradeço muito é a presença de vocês
e a gente se vê na semana que vem.
Eu vou dar uma olhada nas suas
perguntas, nos seus questionamentos,
Eliseu, sobre sono, tá? sacou de
lembrança de sonhos, mas não é uma coisa
assim muito relevante na prática
clínica. Por isso que eu nunca fui atrás
disso aqui.
E mas Denise, então você quando é que
foi isso que você foi mordida aí? Tem
muito tempo.
Você deveria ter tomado antirábica.
Tem quantos dias que você tomou essa
mordida aí?
Deveria ter tomado antirrábica.
Tá
bem, pessoal. Um abraço para vocês. Até
a próxima.